today we're speaking with Liz Schuler
the secretary treasurer of the afl-cio
liz is not only the chief financial
officer for the afl-cio she has a
special interest in responsibility in
working with young people to introduce
the labor movement to them and to learn
from them about what they would like to
see the labor movement of the future
look like
so I'm a secretary treasurer which is
the chief financial officer of the
afl-cio we have 57 affiliated unions and
I actually came up through one of those
unions the International Brotherhood of
Electrical Workers as a rank-and-file
member and my responsibilities here are
to manage the money and make sure that
we're using the dues money wisely and
building program making sure that our
finances are in order but in addition to
that finance hat I also work to engage
educate mobilize young people in our
movement particularly focused as a woman
officer and making sure that we are
engaging women in our labor movement and
really speaking out on issues that
affect women in the workplace and then
sort of in terms of innovation what can
we be doing as a labor movement to
change as the workplace changes and
evolves and that can include anything
from workforce development and training
to issues around the on-demand economy
there's so much happening in the world
of work
well the young people in the labor
movement I was a young person when I
first started in my Union 23 years old
often feel that they don't have as much
of a voice in our labor movement and I
wanted to figure out a way to change
that and make their ideas and opinions
and thoughts and approaches woven into
the fabric of what we do every day so we
started a young worker program we call
next up about six years ago and the
intent was to figure out ways to get
young people engaged in their their own
unions but also making connections with
young people outside the labor movement
so that we're all working together to
advance the interests of young people in
this economy and we've been building
young worker groups all across the
country through our afl-cio structure so
in most major cities and pretty much
every state we have a young worker group
that's giving voice to young people
they're leading in politics in
legislation in organizing and really
being a voice and a presence for the
labor movement in their local
communities I'm really proud of the work
they've done to put together a young
worker economic platform so that they
can hold politicians accountable on the
issues that matter to young people in
the economy and of course front and
center is job opportunities making sure
that when people graduate from high
school or even graduate from college
that we have good jobs waiting for them
and often we know young people are
grappling with a lot of student loan
debt when they've gone through college
and how are our elected officials
responding to that and really connecting
the labor movement to the issues that
matter to young people
well of course is a real opportunity for
young people to connect on what is the
future of work going to look like what
are we doing as working people to
influence that and in the labor movement
of course front and center is collective
bargaining and how can we strengthen
collective bargaining and how does the
role of collective bargaining influence
work in general and we know the
unionized workforce has been shrinking
but in a time of the greatest inequality
we've seen it's more important than ever
that we grow the labor movement and get
our fair share of that growth in the
economy and so I think for young people
who are looking at what can I do to
influence what can I do to help taking a
course like this educating themselves
but then also taking that education and
moving it into action and I think when I
talk to young people they often feel
powerless and don't see the labor
movement as a vehicle for that kind of
action and so I think the message is
that yeah they're there are
opportunities there are places you can
go to exert your power and the power of
coming together and the power of
collective action nowhere is that better
on display than with the labor movement
young people in the labor movement have
a very unique perspective they often are
some of the only young people in their
peer group that have a decent job that
pays benefits that gives them the
training they need without going into
debt so I think that they can do a
service to other young people who may
not know those opportunities exist by
lifting up the possibilities of what the
labor movement can offer they also have
a unique perspective on what's happening
in the economy as we know this
generation has suffered
disproportionately with the lack of
opportunity the economy the unemployment
numbers have hit them I think at double
the rate of the average who's out of
work and you know we want to come
together as a society to figure out what
kind of jobs do we want to see in this
country as we go forward in the future
do we want low road low wage jobs or do
we want opportunities to really support
your family and put food on the table
and I think young people are feeling
that so acutely and so they have ideas
and thoughts to share on how we can
rebuild the economy so I think that this
is a great opportunity to bring people
together have their voices heard make
sure that we're getting our politicians
attention on this because those elected
officials are the ones that write the
rules and pass the policies and so if
we're going to rewrite the rules of the
economy we need to get more and more
young voices in that conversation
I think there is so much opportunity at
this moment in time as of course the
workplace is changing and evolving so is
the labor movement and so is the
progressive infrastructure in the
country and I think the message is that
we don't just have to sit back and wait
for change to happen and and feel like
we can't be a part of that change I
think it's important that you see the
labor movement as a vehicle for that
possibility of bringing people's voice
to get voices together and as an
institution we can do that but we can't
do it alone we need to be working
together in collaboration and in
partnership with all kinds of
organizations and the more people we
bring together the more powerful our
voices are so I think for young people
who are looking for an avenue and a way
to make change certainly look to the
labor movement but look in your
communities look at all the different
organizations that are lifting up voices
in different ways look at your local
businesses for example we often think
that labor and management are at odds
with each other but could we be more
powerful if we were working together in
collaboration on the things that matter
to creating better jobs high road high
wage jobs and so I think that young
people will play an integral and
important role in making that happen